On any given set there are a thousand different
things for the cast and crew to keep in mind
in order to prevent continuity errors and
other mistakes, so it’s no wonder that some
things slip through the cracks.
With TV shows expected to pump out content
at a faster rate than movies, it’s even
more likely that even the best shows overlook
a detail or two.
Fortunately in this age of streaming, binge
watching, and over analyzing, nothing gets
by the Internet.
Here are 10 Shocking Mistakes In Hit TV Shows
The Simpsons
Before you go getting all judgey about your
favourite shows making mistakes, bear in mind
that most continuity errors go unnoticed by
most viewers.
For example, how many times do you think you’ve
seen the classic opening credit sequence of
the Simpsons?
The original opening was used for almost 20
seasons and contained a mistake you probably
saw hundreds of times but never noticed.
When Homer gets of his car and is almost run
over by Marge, you can see a bunch of things
in the back right corner of the garage, but
when it cuts to the next shot, the bike, tools,
rake and all the other clutter are replaced
by a couple boxes.
Friends
Remember The One Where Rachel Wears a Vanishing
Necklace?
At the beginning of this scene Rachel can
be seen wearing one of her typically fashionable
accessories around her neck, but when Ross
shows up with his new girlfriend, it disappears,
then reappears briefly before vanishing completely.
It was early in the series, when Rachel was
still dabbling in the dark arts, nobody talked
about it much.
Game of Thrones
Speaking of magic necklaces, anyone who saw
the season 6 premier of Game of Thrones learned
that Melisandre has a pretty special necklace
herself.
When she removes it, we see that it’s what
provides the old witch with her beautiful
facade.
With no more books from George RR Martin to
guide them, the show runners really seem to
be laying down the track as they go, especially
when you consider Melisandre was shown without
a necklace while bathing in season 4, and
she is clearly no crone.
Walking Dead
When you see promotional stills for movies
or TV shows, they may look like they’re
taken right from the footage but most of the
time they’re actually taken by still photographers
who are on set during filming.
They’re often one step behind the real camera
crew catching the scene, as you can see in
this Walking Dead scene where the stills photographer
doesn’t move in time, and his reflection
is visible as he documents himself ruining
the shot.
Fresh Prince of Bel Air
In the pilot episode of Fresh Prince of Bel
Air, Will makes himself at home in his new
digs by dancing to Soul II Soul and hanging
a Malcolm X poster.
As he punches staples into the wall, you can
see the flimsy set walls waver.
Either the crew didn’t think the show would
last long enough to make the sets a little
more permanent, or Uncle Phil and Aunt Viv
have some serious structural issues to take
care of.
How I Met Your Mother
In Subway wars, the gang tests one another’s
knowledge of New York City transit by seeing
who can find the quickest route to a downtown
restaurant.
In the first scene, Ted uses Bing to bring
up a map on his laptop.
No the mistake isn’t that he’s using Bing,
Microsoft clearly payed for that placement,
the mistake is the location visible in the
top right corner of the browser.
The map may show New York City streets, where
the show takes place, but Bing reveals that
they’re actually in Los Angeles, California,
where the show is filmed.
That 70s Show
You know what the best part of That 70s show
was?
Those 90s toys.
Not to get all Big Bang Theory on them, but
in the episode where Eric tests Red’s Star
Wars knowledge by having him identify characters
from the toys, the figures are not era appropriate.
Star Wars fans and toy collectors will be
able to instantly identify these as 90s reissues,
not the 1977 collection Eric would have.
Contrary to popular belief, it wouldn’t
have been that hard to track down a couple
original figures for this scene, and it would
have been a nice throwback for people who
actually remembered playing with them in those
innocent, pre Jar Jar days.
Buffy The Vampire Slayer
It’s so hard to find good demons these days.
In the season 3 premiere of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer, our hero finds herself fighting a
whole gaggle of demons from another dimension,
luckily for her they don’t seem to be trying
very hard.
At one point Buffy throws a spin kick that
clearly doesn’t make contact, but seeing
nice soft mat lying just off the platform
the demon decides to throw himself on it all
the same.
It must of been a comfy mat, as we can see
the demon just chilling there for the next
couple shots.
In later seasons they would learn to keep
these things off frame.
Breaking Bad
As far as famous pizzas go, it goes the cheese
pizza Buzz eats in Home Alone, then the pie
Spiccoli orders to class in Fast Times at
Ridgemont high, followed closely by the extra
large pepperoni Walter White roofs in Breaking
Bad.
Brian Cranston famously landed the pizza in
the perfect place on the first take.
It was such a funny image that they decided
to leave it there for the remainder of the
episode, though it moves around the roof a
little depending on the shot, and even gains
some extra pepperoni at one point.
It’s presumably just out of frame when the
cousins enter the house, but it should have
been briefly seen as the axe is taken out
of the trunk.
People loved this gag so much the owners of
the actual house have had issues with people
throwing pizzas on their roof.
The Flash
Filmmakers and TV directors often use editing
tricks that make scenes more dramatic but
don’t really make sense if you think about
them in real space and time.
For example, in this scene from The Flash
where Barry is in the crosshairs of Hot and
Cold and Eddie saves his skin may look cool
but let’s take a closer look.
Shots of The Flash and the impending doom
coming his way establish lots of clear space
around them with police cruisers off in the
distance, yet Eddie seems to come out of nowhere
with the shield.
Where did he come from?
How did Hot and Cold not see him?
Either the director hoped we’d be too into
the moment to catch this altered geography,
or Eddie has some secret powers we don’t
know about.
So are we mistaken in calling of these mistakes?
What accidents have you noticed in your favourite
show?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe for more videos like this one.